und wir schalten nach new york zu
johannes hano der eben auch diese
sicherheitsratssitzung der un verfolgt
hat das ist natürlich ein bisschen
schwer nach einem russischen botschafter
dann ein fazit zu fassen und wir haben
sie gestern auch wieder erlebt diese
störmanöver
russlands im sicherheitsrat dann heute
wieder diese doch trotz dieser dreiste
auftritt der ein bisschen die
argumentation des kremls als hätte man
quasi einen ein fax durch geschickt mit
dem redetext erwägt die kammer damit
überhaupt umgehen wie geht damit die uno
um die weltgemeinschaft und auch
journalisten
also das ist eigentlich ganz ehrlich
eines der größten probleme dass wir in
den letzten jahren eigentlich muss man
sagen schon sehen also dass permanente
lüge der russen immer wieder gibt es
neue versionen wir erinnern uns an ma 17
den abschluss dieses mal leise er
flugzeugs über der ukraine hat russland
nachher 26 glaube die waren es
verschiedene versionen angegeben so
verrückte sachen wie zb dass man das
dies irae leichen in das flugzeug
gemacht hätte und dass dann dieses
flugzeug abgeschossen hätte das gleiche
gilt mit dem bio waffen da bohren was
man die letzte woche vorgebrachte also
es sind eigentlich ganz offensichtliche
lügen für unterschiedliche varianten man
will damit zerstreuen man will damit
zwietracht säen man will damit zweifel
auch sehen und das ist ein konzept das
russland seit vielen vielen jahren hier
in den vereinten nationen vorträgt und
das ganze hat ein zimmer darf das glaube
ich nicht unterschätzen was man damit
nämlich macht ist man unterminiert die
glaubwürdigkeit und die das des ganzen
gremiums des sicherheitsrates im
sicherheitsrat ist ja praktisch
handlungsunfähig geworden in den letzten
jahren weil alles was der sicherheitsrat
tun könnte um den frieden zu sichern
oder auch herzustellen scheitert seit
jahren an dem veto russlands und
insofern ist der sicherheitsrat
überhaupt nicht mehr der lage
irgendetwas zu tun russland verhöhnt mit
diesen lügen die es immer wieder
vorträgt verhöhnt den sicherheitsrat und
macht deutlich was ist von ihm hält
nämlich gar nichts russland will diese
weltordnung ist hat sergej lavrov ja
gerade erst erzählt und gesagt aber an
der pressekonferenz mann sei in einem
epochalen kampf um eine neue weltordnung
und es wird eine neue weltordnung geben
man sieht die vereinten nationen
eigentlich mehr oder weniger als eine
von den amerikanern dominiert ordnung
oder als eine institution die eine
weltordnung repräsentiert die von
amerika geführt wird und das will man
zerschlagen woher man auf dem weg
dorthin die institution kaputt machen
kann dann macht man das und genau das
passiert ja gerade wie reagierte
eigentlich die uno wie wir reagieren
diejenigen die da was dran steuern
könnten der zum beispiel der
menschenrechtsrat der vereinten nationen
der steht ja auch ad absurdum
gibt es da zumindest bewegung bei denen
bei den seitenarmen sollen erst mal so
also dazu muss man folgendes sagen in
der sicherheitsrat oder die vereinten
nationen können die zusammensetzung des
menschenrechtsrats an nur mit einer
zweidrittelmehrheit verändern die
amerikaner und die europäer haben gesagt
man wird jetzt bei der
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen einen solchen antrag einbringen
man möchte die vereinten nationen hält
man möchte die russen aus diesem gremium
des un menschenrechtsrats heraus haben
dafür bedarf es einer
zweidrittelmehrheit man wird sehen ob
man die bekommt wenn alles so läuft wie
bei den letzten abstimmungen wo es darum
ging die russland und den krieg in der
ukraine zu verurteilen dann sieht es gut
aus dann gibt es eine solche mehrheit
aber das ist noch lange nicht abgemacht
ich fand eigentlich besonders
bemerkenswert heute präsident zielinski
der eigentlich fielen hier vielen
beobachtern aus dem herzen gesprochen
und er hat gesagt ihr seid einfach nicht
mehr handlungsfähig wenn so was möglich
ist wenn ein sicherheitsratsmitglied
virus dann mit einem veto sozusagen
alles blockieren kann und ein veto
letztlich sterben bedeutet für seine
menschen in der ukraine für seine bürger
dann ist der sicherheitsrat überflüssig
man muss sich überlegen seid ihr in der
lage euch noch zu reformieren dann tut
es jetzt so dann müsst ihr was mit dem
veto machen oder ihr werdet völlig
überflüssig und da müssen wir uns hier
auflösen vor dieser entscheidung steht
hier und das hat er denen heute hier den
sicherheitsratsmitgliedern sehr sehr
deutlich gemacht und mein persönlicher
eindruck ist hier dass es vielen
tatsächlich reicht dass man weiß dass
man so nicht mehr weitermachen kann und
zielinski hat den druck heute erhöht und
hat vielen aus dem herzen gesprochen
es kann durchaus sein dass er eine ganz
neue bewegung in gang kommt das wäre die
frage gewesen er hat sehr stark diese
rolle und auch die arbeitsweise
überhaupt die wirksamkeit angefragt
braucht es dafür einen seelands geht ihr
den spiegel vorhält oder ist er gerade
zur zeit der richtige der zum beispiel
auch sehr deutlich geworden ist und
diesen diesen angriffskrieg und die
gräueltaten der russen mit dem es
verglichen hat
ja also er hat die die gräueltaten der
ruß mit dem märz vergleicht man würde
aus spaß leute mit panzern überfahren
würde leute hinrichten von fahrrädern
schießen man würde sie folgt aus spaß
foltern und vergewaltigen er war da sehr
sehr deutlich und er hat sie als genießt
einen sehr sehr guten ruf nicht bei
allen natürlich also bei den russen
nicht und auch bei syrern und
nordkoreaner nicht aber er genießt im
rest der welt einen großen hof wirkt
sehr authentisch man glaubt ihm und ich
glaube ich schon dass tendenz ließ rolle
eine besondere rolle sein wird das wird
dann werden wir ein paar jahren
feststellen selensky wird eine art
katalysator sein für die welt wie sie
sich neu organisiert und in welche
richtung wir gehen werden das wird ein
katalysator sein für europa aber auch
wie die vereinten nationen er genießt
hohe glaubwürdigkeit man sieht vor der
matrix sozusagen der der der
unglaublichen katastrophe in der ukraine
und seiner führerschaft in dieser krise
sieht man viele dinge die man eigentlich
schon die ganze zeit wusste sieht man
jetzt sehr viel klarer und man hat ich
sag mal vorsichtig eine art helden
gefunden der jetzt in der lage ist
dieses negativ diese erzählung auch
weiter zu tragen und das darf man auch
nicht vergessen die russen haben
versucht immer ihre narrativ
durchzusetzen die ganze zeit das geht
nicht mehr mit einem sinn es geht ja
hier heute gesprochen hat oder ein ganz
klares gegen relativ eine gegen
erzählung aufgestellt hat gegen die
rostock so einfach nicht mehr ankommt
wir haben sie muss noch ganz kurz über
das das video sprechen dass zwar ein
bisschen später dann eingeblendet wurde
dass diese vielen toten ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer zeigt wir haben das einfach
so übernommen auch im programm weil wir
gar nicht wussten dass es so gezeigt
wird und wir es gar nicht mal verpixeln
konnten aber was hat dieses video für
eine wirkung
ich glaube jeder der das video gesehen
hat weiß was das für eine wirkung hat
das ist herzzerreißend also kommen mir
die tränen in die augen ganz ehrlich und
das ist uns hier so gegangen auch im
studio als man das gesehene das ist
natürlich bezweckt das ist eine form
auch muss man ganz klar sagen der
gegenpropaganda um die russischen lügen
etwas hingegen zu stellen diese bilder
sind mächtiger als alle worte die der
russische botschafter sprechen kann wenn
man das mit der eigenen augen sieht
dieses kroll dieses unfassbare leid die
bestialität mit der die menschen dort
umgebracht und zerstückelt wurden
dagegen kommt man mit worten schwer an
und ich glaube genau das war bezweckt
auch um russland hier in eine ecke zu
stellen ich glaube das funktioniert das
thema dankeschön trotzdem westen dank
nach new york johannes hano